the floor I'll just take a mic and the
floor is yours
all right uh very good very good so
welcome back uh welcome back
We are continuing to talk about
applications of sketching in numerical
linear algebra and specifically we will
finish the proof of the theorem on the
slide namely that the count sketch
Matrix with about a d squared number of
buckets is a Subspace embedding with
constant probability and constant
Precision in that particular case great
okay
so just a reminder this is the Matrix
itself exactly one non-zero per every
column B is the number of rows also
known as the number of buckets
and we are using this Matrix to downsize
the least squares regression problem
that we are solving reduce the number of
rows in this big Matrix a down to the
number of buckets that is quadratic in D
after that we find a one plus Epsilon
approximate fit by simply solving the
smaller problem
good so
excellent
back to where we left off uh right so uh
we said look we want to establish the
Subspace embedding property and the
Subspace embedding property is the
property that the euclidean lengths of
all vectors in our Subspace of Interest
should be simultaneously preserved by
our sketch
um good so how can we think about all
vectors in the Subspace of Interest well
we get a
basis for the Subspace we call that a
matrix U this Matrix is n by D it's a
basis for D dimensional Subspace of RN
and the Subspace embedding property says
that with high probability over s the
sketching Matrix it must be the case
that for any Vector of coefficients on
that basis uh this is a vector why uh
the euclidean norm of
sketched version of UI UI is close to
the euclidean norm of the non-sketched
version but since U is a basis it's just
the equilibrium Norm of Y itself
all right good we realized that this
actually is a statement about the
spectral Norm
um about the closeness of the gram
Matrix of the sketched version of our
bases to the identity in the spectral
more but this is the basis you s times U
is the sketched version of the basis so
naturally we lose orthonormality a tiny
bit but this is asking us to prove that
we don't lose too much
all right after that we said well we'll
actually prove the stronger bound namely
uh that the gram Matrix of the sketched
base is as close to the identity in the
frobenius norm
and that was great because a frobenius
norm
squared of the difference between two
matrices
separates over the entries of The Matrix
so at this point if we're shooting for a
frobenius norm closeness bound all that
we need to do is take all
pairs
of basis vectors UI and u j there are D
Squared of those and then we need to
just compare the dot product between
them
functions
the Delta function of I equals to J to
the dot product between the sketched
vectors so that's what we want to prove
that basically hashing with random signs
which is what cloud sketch is almost
preserves dot products for two vectors X
and Y and RN we want to prove that the
dot product between counts cached
versions is close to the original one
great so then we just looked at some
example uh we said well here are two
vectors in dimension eight and here's a
hash function let's compare the dot
product between the original vectors and
the hash vectors
some amount of
observation reveals that
the difference between the dot product
and the dot product between count
sketched vectors is basically a bunch of
cross terms
have a if we have some collisions inside
the hash pocket then we'll get
contributions corresponding to for every
two coordinates
in N that collided in this bucket or we
get the extra term which is the product
of Sines times the product of the
corresponding valve
so in full generality this is what it
looks like
[Music]
um
the dot product between count sketched X
and count sketched Y is the original dot
product plus the sum overall buckets
over all pairs of coordinates between 1
and N that are distinct hash to the same
buckets of this
um it's an unbiased estimator simply
because I can put expectations on top of
everything and the expectation for
product of two random signs is zero
good so our task was to compute the
variance and this is what we will do now
any any questions about uh about the
setup
cool
um
very nice so what is the variance it's
just the expected squared deviation from
the mean and as we saw the deviation
from the mean is exactly this sum of
cross terms over all the buckets so
we'll just go and square the sum
and hope for the best all right so we
squared the sum and it resulting
expression is a little bit annoying
um
there was a sum over all buckets and
overall pairs of coordinates that hash
into the same bucket but we're squaring
this so now what happens is there are
two buckets B and B Prime and play with
every bucket B and B Prime uh there are
two coordinates Associated I and J and I
Prime and J Prime
so I and J are distinct I Prime and J
Prime are distinct
but we overlap uh the two pairs could
overlap and the conditions that I and J
has to be I Prime and G Prime has to be
Prime
fantastic so we need to understand the
expectation of this uh now
we just put expectation on top but
uh before we put expectations on top
let's just color this expression so it
becomes a little bit more colorful and
hopefully easier to understand uh so we
color everything related to B red and
everything related to B Prime blue and
here is the picture that goes along with
us so there's B and B Prime and the I
and the J hash into B and B uh I Prime
on J Prime hashing two
now the first observation is
um that if we take the expectation of
both sides
and then we actually get to ignore we
get to just immediately drop all the
terms where V and B Prime are different
why is that suppose that B and B Prime
are different if they are then the pair
i j the set I comma J does not overlap
with the set I prime J Prime
well if they don't then we are taking
the expectation of a product of four
distinct random signs we will assume
that the signs are four Y is independent
we need it for this analysis in which
case all of these terms are zero in
expectation
very good
okay so this so we'll put the
expectations on top and this simplifies
things a tiny bit
so now suddenly we don't have a b Prime
it's just a summation over B uh good
but the I and I prime J and J Prime they
still remain so now we're interested in
summation over all buckets and inside a
given bucket there could be a number of
coordinates colliding so we're summing
over
pairs I comma J those are distinct I
prime J prime those are distinct that
hash into the same bucket
good
so again
uh we have these random signs that are
four Y is independent we note that I
want to simplify this a little bit more
uh let's look at the inter overlap
pattern of I the set I and J and I Prime
and J Prime these are sets of size two
and I claim that if they overlap by one
element then the corresponding term is
zero in expectation
right because if these two sets overlap
by one element
exactly then the remaining elements are
unmatched and they're
good so what does this mean this means
that uh
this means that there are two options
either I equals I Prime
or I equals J Prime so two ways of
matching things
so zero overlap is also zero zero
overlap is also zero yes thank you zero
yes
the only possibility that the product of
Sines is non-zero also known as one in
expectation is that either I equals I
Prime and J equals J prime or the other
way around
and uh this is uh yeah this is what we
get
so note that so now we can write this as
a sum over all before we had a sum over
all I and J that hash into the
um into the corresponding bucket B but
we can rewrite this as a sum over all
coordinates I and J
um and then
add the constraint that they must hash
to the correct bucket uh
I and J both have to given bucket B with
probability one over B squared
so I removed I took the expectation over
the hash function and put a 1 over B
squared term up front
okay so we also sum over B buckets so
let's just cancel one B uh and and
that's what we get
all right
um oh fantastic let's just simplify the
right hand side
okay
[Music]
um
so the right hand side is over all I and
J and n i distinct from J
so let's just throw in the terms I
equals J
these are non-negative and when I equals
J these are also non-negative
so this only increases the sum so now we
have the sum of over all I and J
completely unconstrained of x i squared
YJ squared plus X I uh y j
x j y i squared
and so this is nothing but the
the first the first thing is just the
product of euclidean norms squared of X
and Y and the second term is just the
squared dot product between X and Y
Now by cautious words the second part is
at most the first so we get all in all
uh we get that the variance is upper
bounded by uh well at least this part if
the variance is upper bounded by two
times the product of euclidean norms
squared
good any any questions about this
okay
uh good good so let's just restore the
one of our B uh factors just put this
together no we we have these two vectors
X and Y and we wanted to understand how
close X transpose Y is to count sketch
text transfers accounts cached Y what
did we get uh we get that it's uh
basically one over two over a number of
buckets that we hash into times the
product of euclidean norms closed
uh so in particular this means by
championships inequality that with
constant probability we get an additive
error of one over square root number of
buckets times the product of euclidean
numbers note that if you were to just
let's say do JL just do dimensionality
reduction that preserves uh in that case
you need to say project onto one over
Epsilon squared or so gaussians right
then you would preserve euclidean Norms
up to a one plus minus Epsilon factor
and that's the type of guarantee you
would also get for the dot products so
dot products you can preserve up to
Advantage
suppose
there's an S5 oh yes
ah thank you sorry
thank you
all right uh very good so now we have a
good bound on the
uh variance uh one of the variance of
um on the variance of our approximation
to the dot product
but remember what we really wanted was
to prove that the gram Matrix of the
sketched basis for our Subspace is close
in a spectral Norm to
identity and we ultimately decided that
it's enough to do for obedience Norm
let's apply our knowledge here so what
is the frobenius norm squared distance
between these two matrices well for
being a storm squared of a matrix is a
summation of the square squares of all
the entries
so let's sum over all the entries of
this Matrix that's a d by D Matrix right
so we're summing over all I and J and D
um
and what are the what are their values
right so this identity is just the gram
Matrix of the basis vectors
all right it was an orthonormal basis
and uh the the first thing is exactly
the
dot product between the count sketch
factors
so the expectation all the expectation
is missing here sorry about that that's
a typo so this expectation here
expectation of the square is exactly
what we just bound
good so for every I and J this is
bounded by 2 divided by B times the
product of euclidean norms squared of
the corresponding basis vectors
right
UI is our X and u j is our y
um
good so so what at the end of the day we
get 2 over B times the square of the
frobenius Norm squared
of our U Matrix U was a basis
so every column
every column of U actually has euclidean
Norm one right so here inside the sum
I'm summing over all the columns of uh
I'm summing the squared euclidean Norms
they're all one so actually what is
inside here is d
all right and then we're squaring it but
it's a this is actually a convenient uh
form uh we'll we'll get a more
interesting result in a second using
this form of the bound okay so all in
all to summarize this is 2 by B times
the fourth Norm or the fourth power of
the forbinius norm of the basis and
that's D Squared
2D squared divided by B
yes I'm just thinking through the
various calculation on the previous
slide is it clear we had to do it again
versus it didn't generically follow from
the count sketch guarantee like we
couldn't have looked at like SX plus Y
and SX minus y and like the variance on
that would have implied the appropriate
inner product
it just seems you approximate L2 Norms
you tend to get that inner product
statements I was trying to think if
that's generic or just uh an intuition
uh
oh are you saying whether is your
question whether the bound on the
variance that we just did already follow
us from what we did in lecture one
right good that's an excellent question
the answer is no it doesn't uh because
it's uh it's one you know one order up
this is a different order and quantity
right uh
when we were doing the original bubbles
we were interested in understanding
individual entries uh so towards
confirming this did we actually need
higher order Independence to get that
guarantee
exactly
exactly okay so for example here uh note
that we needed forward Independence
whereas the vanilla accounts cash
guarantee on approximating the entrance
of the lecture only requires 200. so
[Music]
do not imply that account sketch
preserves you is a dimensional to
reduction
and now we have
yeah
okay uh beautiful uh so so so so yes now
we're done all right because oh we
showed that
the expected frabinius Norm squared
distance between this account sketched
the the gram Matrix of the count sketch
basis and the identity is well
2D by B squared and remember that we
wanted this verbenius Norm squared to be
at most Epsilon squared with high
probability
all right so now we can just apply
markups and equality
[Music]
okay so we just proved that the
expectation
of the
genius Norm
distance
between our gram Matrix and the item and
the identity is at most 2 D Squared over
B so now if we choose B to be at least
2D squared over Epsilon Delta then then
what then the expectation
of our forbidness distance
is it most how much Epsilon squared
times Delta
all right so the probability that
actually is bigger than Epsilon squared
is at most Delta
so this is by markov's import
okay
Square on the Epsilon in the bound on B
uh yes that's the title yes that was
meant to be absolutely
all right good
okay and so in particular then the
spectral Norm is at most Epsilon again
with probability one minus two
very nice
uh questions everybody happy
yes
we did the proof by controlling each
entry of this Matrix right yes but is
there intuition for why you expect that
spectral number for Venus Norm thing to
be tight oh uh good so the question was
uh we did the proof by
bounding the individual entries and and
the difference Matrix right and
which seems weak right in particular
methods that sushant mentioned the ones
that come from Matrix Bernstein's
equality the ghost go straight for the
spectral Norm the question is why is
this uh why is this good uh well
uh well well
um
one answer is that it's good because it
is uh right it just so happens that
the spectral Norm bound fails exactly on
the verbena's number does all right but
I think that uh
I think they're probably under some
assumptions on The Matrix itself right
on the basis itself uh in particular if
the Matrix U is not really close to an
identity on D coordinates and then I
think one can do better and there I
think also probably uh Matrix Bernstein
bounds will be helpful all right
um yeah but here just because there are
examples where these two bounds are the
same
okay bye
all right uh good good so
um summary we showed that if we count
sketch into D Squared by Epsilon squared
buckets then we get a Subspace embedding
namely instead of searching for the
optimal fit for the original problem we
might as well uh measure the quality of
fit in the reduced and reduce space and
we get roughly the same results
get a one plus Epsilon approximate
solution in a time lnz of a time to
reduce the size of the Matrix plus a
poly d by Epsilon so what is the poly D
Squared uh D to the fourth rather right
so we have a D Squared by D Matrix so if
we just use classical techniques to do
the inversion then it will be uh fourth
power
all right
well remember that as I started talking
about first I actually talked about the
rich regression problem that's where we
want to regularize and do we add a
Lambda euclidean Norm of x squared a
term to our objective function
I said that we'll assume that Lambda is
zero for Simplicity and I promise to get
back to you on this so now I will okay
um
in general as sushant was pointing out
if Lambda the regularization term is
very very big this seems like an easy
problem so then solving this problem
approximately shouldn't be all that hard
and indeed
intuitively if Lambda is Big then we're
essentially asking that we don't we're
essentially saying that we don't really
care about eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of a that are below square root of
Lambda will make this a precise in a
second so generally if a is
approximately low rank relative to
Lambda then we should be doing better
and indeed we we are
so here's a theorem that one can show I
think from the same the analysis will be
roughly the same from the paper of
Avalon and Woodruff
for the regularized least squares
problem uh we can find a solution an
approximate one plus Epsilon solution n
time n in Z of a plus poly of poly of s
Lambda actually s Lambda times d
the other The Matrix also the D does not
go down all right
um where s Lambda is the statistical
dimension of a statistical dimension of
a relative to regularization Lambda so
what is the statistical Dimension s
Lambda
um
it is the following expression
uh formally it's the trace of a plus
Lambda I inverse times a and that is
also known as the sum over all J from 1
to D Lambda J divided by Lambda J plus
Lambda where Lambda J is the J
eigenvalue of a transpose a
okay
um good let me give you some intuition
for this quantity so why is this a very
reasonable quantity
well first I want to point out that it
kind of has a the same head and tail
flavor as we saw in the count sketch
analysis
note that statistical dimension of a are
to constant factors is the number of
eigenvalues in a transpose a uh above
Lambda
um
so
in in a actually above Lambda plus the
sum eigenvalue the sum of eigenvalues
below Lambda divided by lamb
okay so this is similar to our analysis
and count sketch where recall we needed
the number of buckets that we hash into
to be at least the number of head
elements of the top K that we're trying
to approximate and then the estimation
error somehow the norm of the tail
divided by square root of B the tail
errors then evenly divided
the one thing is this
I'm wondering if we want the statistical
rank of a transpose a rather than a
because a is a tall skinny Matrix yeah I
think that that's what I've been around
and and you should like as we the
singular values should be comparable to
root Lambda whereas this expression has
them in linear so I think it's a
statistical rank of a transpose a yes
let's uh yeah exactly okay so here's a
proof okay thanks so what I wrote there
was incorrect but now there's actually a
duration the duration is correct all
right thanks a lot yeah uh good so
basically how does this work well recall
that uh in this proof that we did we
worked with a basis uh U or for the
Subspace and the basis is what uh is a
times a transpose a to the minus a half
that's the Matrix U and right so then
the frobenius norm squared of that
Matrix was the dimension of the space
the number of columns now we can I claim
that we can do the exact same proof
replacing the Matrix U with the Matrix a
times a transpose a plus Lambda I to the
minus a half
okay and the euclidean norm squared the
forbidius norm squared of that Matrix uh
is going to be the statistical Dimension
the verbena is not squared of a matrix
is the trace of that Matrix transpose
with itself and so by some cyclic
property of Trace we get exactly the the
right thing and indeed as sushant points
out it has to be a transformation yeah
so
is it the case that basically
you look at how many dimensions you need
to solve this optimization problem yeah
and it's a good solution in
that many dimensions
you basically somebody will preserve
that all those dimensions and you're
fine is that that's roughly the
intuition right so no this formula 70s
is a bit wrong relationship this needs
to be a transpose a as we just saw but
uh note that this expression uh is
indeed uh nothing but up to constant
factors the number of eigenvalues evolve
so Lambda plus the sum of eigen values
below Lambda divided by lamb
let's take a moment to verify that that
is the case suppose that Lambda J is
bigger than a Lambda right the Lambda J
over Lambda G Plus Lambda is roughly one
or two of the constant Factor you can
drop the land in that case if Lambda J
is below Lambda uh then in the
denominator you drop the Lambda J we get
a factor two approximation so you're
basically just summing up contributions
below so what you're saying is correct
except it misses the fact that you could
have a very long tail that is somehow
also happening
yes exactly yeah
good all right
um fantastic so that's what I wanted to
say about the vanilla least squared
regression uh together with the
regularized version let me say a few
words okay I do have a bit of time
that's great about
kernelized versions of this yes
we're moving on one more for being a
storm question
so suppose we Define Subspace embeddings
to be like the verbenius norm
approximation so for all you so we have
the distribution of our assets and for
all of you like different genius
I mean it's like less than Epsilon is
the D Squared over is like the D Squared
dependence optimal for that or I think
they do better for problem like like
what
what how many rows would you need to
have like constant probability of that
video because of these these examples
that I gave right so if you're such
faces it's just a coordinate Subspace on
some human sort of coordinate sizes
let's show that D Squared yeah yeah
right yes basically it doesn't matter
how you find that you can Define
Subspace and lettings
because of
coordinate subspaces so in summary
questions if you define the discipline
for being a storm problem what we just
saw was optimal if you'd wanted actual
two Subspace submittings and there are
constructions yes yes
and you can do deal perhaps
there are two questions here so first I
can generally construct a Subspace in
the bedroom yes I understand that so if
you define the Subspace embedding in
terms of the spectral Norm right and
they're better constructions in terms of
the number of rows yes so you just take
gaussians exactly you're happy uh if you
define it with respect to the forbidness
non-bound these are optimal uh anyway
right
that was the question no I said I
thought you were more constrained to
complication uh no I was wondering just
the object
so I wonder if we saw
the app for like for being a storm
Association
together so I sort of yeah
but uh yeah
that's uh yeah
so thank you yeah
and you need if you uh if you know more
about your use
far from According to some spaces I'm
pretty sure
thanks
all right
well fantastic so let me talk a little
bit about sort of non-linear versions of
this so
so right now we're
linearization
[Music]
of some function and we want to fit this
function by a linear function of the
statements so
kernel Ridge regression which I will not
really do the fine details of is the
following question we're given a
sequence of D dimensional data points
and again here's a one-dimensional
example X1 through xn and we're given
this together with evaluations of some
function and we're trying to fit the
function but we're no longer trying to
fit it with a linear function but we're
trying to find a fit
from some class of nice smooth functions
so here's an example of an example of
some some function evaluated this is the
true function it's something weird some
sign of a bunch of Sines and cosines of
sorts uh and noise evaluations uh one
can try to find an approximation of this
from a class of smooth functions and for
example if you do kernel retrogression
with a gaussian kernel then you get a
pretty good fit I don't think I have a
picture for that right now but the idea
for example is
uh if you're doing kernel regression
with the gaussian kernel you're
basically saying that you will seek to
approximate the function of Interest by
a sum of gaussian bumps around your data
your data points okay so that's that's
kernel regression some non-linear
version
good uh
so the main computational effort in
kernel regression is the volume where
given the data points they Define a
kernel Matrix an example kernel Matrix
is the gaussian kernel Matrix where the
ijth entry of the Matrix is just e to
the minus euclidean distance squared uh
maybe by two between your data points
and you want to invert a regularized
version of this and do a kernel a matrix
Vector product where Y is the vector of
labels
okay so what is this kernel Matrix in
reality this kernel Matrix actually is
the gram Matrix of some feature
embedding of your data points so here's
a pictorial a representation of this
let's say the gaussian kernel itself uh
is in fact the gram Matrix of the N
input data points let me draw that in
there for you
actually
okay so let's say the gaussian kernel
Matrix can be thought of as a transpose
a where this Matrix a is an infinite
number of rows it
it's a little bit informal but you know
that's that's how it goes uh basically
the
every data point x i
corresponds to a column of this Matrix
right and the column itself is just the
evaluation of the function e to the
minus x minus x i squared
something else
this is the pictorial directional thing
the feature embedding of a point is
um is an infinite dimensional object
just the evaluation of some gaussian
centered at this point
good
uh good and so now what we would like to
achieve is is the following
right now we designed Subspace
embeddings and Subspace embeddings are
the following objects they are
embeddings that can be applied to the
large dimension of some Matrix a to
reduce the dimensionality and at the
same time
once we squish the large dimension of
the Matrix we preserve the geometry of
the corresponding Subspace
we designed a random Matrix a s such
that
with high probability
R over s following is true
okay
and this is for every y
EP right
so we have a matrix a that defines a
Subspace we squish the large dimension
of the Matrix while ensuring that the
euclidean Norms of the squished and
non-squished vectors are preserved with
high probability for every Vector in the
corresponding subsidies that's what we
did and now I would like to apply this
in the setting of Kernel matrices
again in the setting of Kernel matrices
I'm given these n data points now very
important to the little n now is what
used to be D
all right and what is what used to be n
the large dimension in this setting is
infinite
and okay so I have this Matrix with an
infinite Dimension uh the the large one
and the smaller one is N I would like to
apply an oblivious Subspace embedding to
the large dimension
so one option is of course to try to
count sketch but it's a little bit
awkward because then it needs to map uh
the real line on into some buckets so
basically what we would like to do is is
to design a Subspace embedding can be
applied that can be applied uh
implicitly without fully forming this
feature map fully forming the uh
the actual High dimensional Vector okay
and this is useful for kernel Ridge
regression I will not get it to the
details here very much all right good so
this is uh
the gaussian kernel is one example of a
current also another one that will be
useful for the subsequent discussion is
the polynomial kernel
here's another way to embed points let's
say we can take a point x and map it to
XX transpose so the second tensor power
of of X so this would be the degree two
polynomial kernel or we can consider
higher tensor powers okay and so here's
the question can we design Subspace
embeddings can that can be uh applied
implicitly
good
uh so this brings us to our puzzle from
the first lecture today namely count
sketch for matrices this is really why
we're interested uh remember that there
are these are parties that held vectors
X1 through x r right and we were then
interested in finding the top uh
coefficients in
in the sum of outer products of the X
I's
good
um good so then we just we defined the
following tensored version of count
sketch where instead of having a single
hash function that Maps
the N squared dimensional domain down to
B buckets we actually had two hash
functions that map the individual
coordinates and two sine functions then
we transfer them so this is the
construction of the pay and the thumb
that I mentioned before known as the
tensor sketch good so this is a sketch
with the very structured hash functions
as I mentioned
the answer to the puzzle was that we
should use Fourier transforms so to
compute the sketch it is enough to just
sketch the vector X using sketch number
one education number two and then one
can convince oneself that all that you
need to do is take these two sketches
and convolve them okay and this you can
do using fast Fourier transfer
foreign
another very nice exercise that is
related to the question of how much
Independence you need for approximating
DOT products between sketched vectors is
to compute the variants
of
do the same computation that we did just
for count sketch except in the setting
of the tensored construction all right
and I will not solve the exercises it's
an interesting exercise because that's
where issues with Independence come up
in particular one I can verify that the
signs that we get this way are not four
wise independent so the direct analysis
that we did the standard analysis does
not quite go through the problem is that
for instance if you take uh two if you
take four points that are corners of a
rectangle right then the sine function
the product of sine functions is
identically one so despite the fact that
you have four distinct points the
corresponding contributions do not
cancel an expectation you get a one as
opposed to a zero
right okay so a nice exercise one can
also ask how this could be extended to
higher tensor powers and it can
another one simply tensors uh as many
column sketches as one likes and one can
compute the corresponding sketch using
the fast Fourier transform as before the
counts cache analysis goes through one
can ask whether this tensorized sketch
will give us a Subspace embedding for
the polynomial kernel of a degree q and
the answer is yes it's the same result
of avalonian and Woodruff in 2019 except
that this
the dependency issue that I alluded to
before really becomes serious while for
degree 2. degree two kernels the
performance of this is roughly as good
as for standard account sketch if the
power of the polynomial that you're
interested in goes goes up the
dependence of the number of buckets is
exponential so you need three to the Q
times statistical Dimension squared
buckets and this is really sharp so
this is needed
so here's an interesting question that
we ask Sometimes some time ago uh the
question is
Define and schedule the polynomial
dependence on the degree parameter Q
um and uh here is an outline of how this
can be done so this is from a paper of
myself with a lot of other people
um
essentially instead of taking this
beautiful idea of pay and farm that
shows that you can buy fft tensorize
account sketch many times and very
efficiently
um
one tensorizes in a slightly more
careful way essentially if you just take
a tensor product of all the counts
caches at the same time the dependencies
accumulate and they accumulate
exponentially instead what we do is we
consider a tree of sketches if you want
to transfer you can see the construct a
sketch for the Q tensor power of your
vector then this tree will have q leaves
at the bottom just like in tensor sketch
you will have independent sketches of
the vector X except that these
independent sketches will then be joined
by intermediate nodes and these
intermediate nodes only use a tensor
sketch of farm and say
with the degree 2 and the sufficiently
large number of buckets so somehow I
don't have too much time to get into the
details but if the intermediate sketches
use a sufficiently large number of
buckets instead of having a dependence
which is a fixed a fixed constant raised
to power Q or one is able to get a blow
up of the variance that is more like one
plus one over the degree to power the
degree and this never blows up
so there's just some dependence on the
ultimate degree in the number of buckets
in the intermediate nodes
great okay so this is just a rough
outline how does that how does one apply
this Subspace embedding for for the
polynomial kernel to the gaussian kernel
which is the kernel of great interest in
many applications uh well that's by
Taylor expansions
so let me outline this
as mentioned before the gaussian kernel
is what the ijth entry of the kernel
Matrix is e to the minus euclidean
distance squared by two perhaps between
the two points so just for intuition
let's assume that all the points lie on
this here of some radius let's say
radius one yeah this is really not a
problem ultimately then
the kernel Matrix between points and
this here is nothing but e raised to
power the dot product between the
corresponding vectors maybe up to some
constant that depends on the radius of
the points okay
when Taylor expands the exponential
and therefore observes that the gaussian
kernel can be written as a sum of
gram matrices of polynomial kernels of
various degrees
for example
infinite sum is from K from zero to
Infinity one over key factorial times
the gram Matrix of the kth tensor power
of your data set and then at the end of
the day all that one needs to do is
sketch the individual uh
uh especially the individual
kth tensor powers and out comes a
Subspace embedding for the gaussian for
the gaussian kernel there is one
constraint here our result is pretty
close to tight under the assumption that
the data set has bounded radius
um
the reason why there is dependence on
the radius is that well you need to take
the exponential and just truncate it
after a certain number of terms and how
many terms you truncated after is a
function of the maximum euclidean Norm
of your vectors
good uh
this is nice
up to this polynomial dependence on the
radius which I think is completely
unnecessary and here is a very
interesting open problem namely remove
the dependence on the radius in these
sketches for kernel matrices
essentially the way I think about this
is that now this is trying to design a
high dimensional version of fast but
multiple methods of green gourd and
roughly okay so kernel matrices arise
prominently for example in particle
simulations in numerical analysis where
you have and data points and they
interact through some shift invariant uh
Force like gravity or electrostatic
force and a very powerful method known
as the fast multiple method was due to
greenguard and Rothman in in the 80s led
to Revolution in particle physics
simulations basically it let lets one
apply less one compute kernel Matrix
Vector products for shift invariant
kernels in time nearly linear in the
number of particles in your system
except with one important caveat the
caveat is that there is a there is an
exponential dependence on Dimension and
indeed these codes become very expensive
in dimension 3 for example
uh good the way this works is by
taking the data points uh partitioning
in them into geometric regions there's
some grids at various uh level various
levels of resolution imposed and then
inside every bounded box one Taylor
expands the kernel in some way okay so
the current state of affairs here I
would describe as uh the Taylor
expansions that the classical fast
multiple methods use in high Dimensions
suffer exponentially from the dependent
from the dependence on the dimension
well if you do a Taylor expansion in
dimension D up to Precision Epsilon
you'll typically get log one over
Epsilon to the D terms so what we have
right now is a method for sketching a
high dimensional Taylor expansion in one
cell of the fast multiple method but we
don't know how to patch things together
across different scales and that I think
is a very exciting open problem we
recently made some nice progress towards
that I would say in some meta sense with
the Moses and Eric going Garden uh it's
not quite the linear regression problem
it's more kernel density estimation but
it seems relevant so I'm very hopeful
okay good
that's that's all I have on numerical
linear algebra through account sketch
um
I think
should we adjourned and then what do you
think I wanted to yeah maybe let's do
questions yeah I want to do quite we'll
do quite
how about we do questions give us a
quick taste of what to come after the
breakup yeah so wait let's first thank
you
thank you thank you
questions
do you think you can read both of the
panels in R and exponential depends on
the on the dimension I think so yes
that's what I would like to do right
basically right now yeah we know how to
get rid of the exponential dependence on
the dimension but not the r
yes I'm very optimistic yes
I don't know how but I think it's job
good way to think about the effective
dimension of the gaussian kernel Matrix
oh a statistical dimension of the
gaussian parallel Matrix is that the
right notion of Dimension oh yes thank
you Moses uh right I uh yes okay
uh indeed
um
it's an interesting question how should
we
evaluate sketching algorithms for kernel
matrices uh
statistical Dimension is a very nice
notion that came out of uh the work on
sketching explicitly given matrices it
makes a lot of sense for example if you
ask the question uh
I have a matrix
which is explicitly given to me uh
let's say it has n rows and D columns
you know how many bits of information do
I need to write down this Matrix all
right and D times statistical Dimension
is a pretty good answer why because no
your Matrix might actually be a
projection onto an s lambda-dimensional
space maybe you just have a projection
Matrix how many bits do you need to
write down a projection matrix it's D
times s Lambda so these bounds are
basically very natural that's the
information complexity of the problem in
some sense but now if I have a kernel
matrix it's implicitly given by some D
dimensional data points and I'm thinking
D might be it's just some poly log let's
say make D large enough so that it's
heightened very high dimensional so
nothing exponential works right then the
points itself the points themselves can
be described pretty succinctly and at
least I don't really see a reason
anymore why you need number of points
times statistical dimension of the
Matrix number of bits to represent this
maybe just low rank approximations are
not necessarily the best way to do
linear algebra on kernel matrices yeah I
I don't yet have a good
alternative but but the hope is that
somehow one can uh bring geometric
information into into the picture
but then for example for the identity
Matrix it has a very high statistical
Dimension but it's also very easy to
sketch
wait
uh the identity Matrix
um
I guess I'm thinking the about these
tall and skinny matrices when you mean
identity do you oh do you mean that I
mean you can just consider a lot of very
separated points right then their kernel
Matrix would be an identity Matrix right
so the numerical linear algebra with
them should be very simple I think I can
yeah but it has a high statistical
Dimension yes exactly so I think this
statistical Dimension therefore is not
very nice it's not good for current
images
yes I don't know what the equivalent is
that would be very nice to design
something
any more questions
I want to say a few words about it after
the yes yes so uh good so after the
break I will talk about graph sketching
and uh I will I originally plan to cover
graph connectivity using sketches but I
don't think I I have time so instead I
will just go straight for spectral
approximation of graphs using a
sketching almost probably
um
we will learn how to solve the following
abstract problem so the problem is this
suppose that you you bought a house
and it's a very old house and you're
worried about the wiring
in the walls because the wiring is old
and it might overheat okay so you don't
have the plans for the house but
you're looking at the wall so here is
the wall of your house
you don't know where the wires are
but some old plans somehow tell you
where the Junctions between the wires
are so these are vertices of some graph
okay so you look at this wall uh and you
want to find the wires that shortcut so
these are wires of high effective
resistance okay
uh
you want to know where they are these
are edges of some graph because they
might overheat and cause a fire so you
need to find them what can you do you're
staring at this wall and you have a
battery in hand it's a bit of a funky
bat right it lets you do this you choose
any pair of points and then you send one
unit of current
from one to the other so it's a
current Source okay so you attach it and
then you feel the wall with your hands
and
if some spots are hot
then you know that there is a wire that
overheats there right this feeling the
wall with your hand will be the count
sketch algorithm okay uh good and then
the question is
how many tests
do you need to do How many pairs of
points do you need to hook up your funky
battery to in order to find all the
shortcuts okay
so from sushant's lectures it already
should be quite clear that to find all
the shortcuts it's enough to just take
all try all the pairs quadratic number
of pairs and a wire has high effective
resistance if under this experiment it
will you know contribute a lot of energy
so you'll feel it
but you don't have all day you don't
want to run a quadratic number of tests
you want to do it faster we will learn
how to do this in about a linear number
of tests
the tests you're doing here just for St
demands or can they be St we'll only do
a point to point
we'll try about Empires great thank you
very much
so I will have a breakdown until 3 30
and
for to see you all for the last Talk of
the day